hello everybody as you can see a
different studio today I this is the our
other car or the big car as our kids
call it or as my wife my wife says that
it's her car because it has all the car
seats in it and so she's the one driving
it around for most of the day but i
strenuously object to that description
of it anyway
over the course of the of this past
weekend some controversy erupted
and you know it's a big deal when
there's controversy I mean in our
society if there's controversy you know
something serious has happened because
it's it's controversy is so rare these
days right it's like there's hardly ever
anything that people are outraged about
so if they're getting outraged you know
that it can't be frivolous right so in
this case the outrage the anger the hurt
the heartbreak the sadness was directed
at former NFL kicker jay Feely and you
see jay Feely posted a photo on twitter
this is a former NFL kicker who posted a
photo on Twitter so we know as I said we
know it's serious business and the photo
depicted him posing with his daughter
and her prom date and feely has his arm
around his daughter kind of protective
but in this sort of protective way and
then his other hand is holding a gun mmm
a gun
shooty thing okay a shooty shooty
dangerous thing and so this is a classic
dad joke I mean this is it's even cliche
it's a dad joke that ten years ago
nobody would have noticed or really
cared maybe a few people would have
laughed most people would have rolled
their eyes because that as I dad I know
that that's the really the appropriate
response to a dad joke is just to roll
your eyes and move on but this is not
ten years ago this is 2018 and so in
2018 the photo went viral with thousands
of people expressing their righteous
indignation at this terrible awful
offensive photo now before I go any
further I need to stipulate that when I
talk about when I say people were
outraged and they were angry just keep
in mind that there are really there are
quotes around that there are cast ik air
quotes around outrage and anger because
as I've said before the the main thing
about the collective outrage that goes
on is that there's very little authentic
outrage in it
I mean I don't think
anyone really actually cared that much
about what jay Feely posted most of the
things when we get this this huge
outrage everyone's so angry most of the
people who are outraged and angry they
are not really outraged or angry what
they're doing is they're just they're
just seizing on this opportunity to make
a point and to destroy somebody and we
know that that's not that's that's
that's been going on since the dawn of
time what makes it different now as it
used to be you know if you were a
politician or a political figure of some
kind and you said anything at all then
yeah you're gonna have people from the
other side who tried to take your words
and use it against you to try to win
right and I think it you that used to
mainly be reserved for people like that
people who are in controversial jobs or
jobs that inherently involved
controversy but now what we find is that
anybody at all it's just any any old
average person doesn't matter what you
do for a living doesn't matter who you
are it doesn't matter what side you fall
on it doesn't matter if you're
completely apolitical anything just just
anyone at all if you put something out
there publicly people will seize on it
and try to destroy you to the point
where even an NFL kicker he's just a
retired NFL kicker I mean even if what
he did was terribly you know this even
if that photo really was legitimately
awful which of course it isn't but even
if it was who cares it's just an NFL
kicker what does it matter I mean what
why would anyone care what he posts just
let him be just let it just whatever so
he's got a who cares there's what what
are you hoping to win or accomplished by
taking this and making a thing out of it
so the anger is is is not really
authentic but be that as it may we will
deal with it anyway so this fake anger
seems to be based on two things one they
say that he's making light of gun
violence and it's dangerous to have a
gun out like that
they said
I saw a lot of people so if that was my
son I would be so I would I would be so
angry that he put him in harm's way with
that gun
because these people think that a gun
through some mysterious gravitational
force could actually load itself and
then point itself and and and and pull
its own trigger that's what they think
could happen but in reality the gun was
did not pose a threat to anybody because
it wasn't loaded and he had it pointed
down and he didn't even have his finger
on the trigger so really that put that
gun posed as much of a threat to the
people in that photograph as there would
have been a threat if he was holding
like a pancake or something it just it
posed zero threat whatsoever but the
other source of outrage is the one that
I want to focus on plenty of feminists
were scandalized or pretended to be
scandalized because as they put it
feely was treating his daughter as
property
and how dare he I'm just as one example
feminist Lauren dukkha or do so I don't
know how to pronounce her name but she's
got a lot of Twitter followers and which
means she's important by the way so the
she said that the photo was a violent
reminder that feely considers his
daughter to be his property now first of
all jay Feely did well he didn't quite
apologize but he did post something
clarifying the tweet and explaining it
which I wish he hadn't even done that
much because it required no explanation
and it required no clarification and
anybody who was offended by it did their
feelings do not matter at all in this
case but I understand why he did because
like I said he's not a political figure
he's not he's not like a pilot or even
someone like me where I know that
everything I say they're gonna be people
who try to take him and and I'm gonna
get hate mail and everything I so I know
that I know that's what I do for a
living so I understand it but jay Feely
that's not what he's he wasn't that's
not what he's looking for he just
thought he was posting a funny picture
it turned into a whole thing so he's
like fine I'll just post something
clarifying and what he said was the prom
picture I posted was obviously intended
to be a joke
my daughter has dated her boyfriend for
over a year and they knew I was joking
I take gun safety seriously the gun was
not loaded and had no clip in it and I
did not intend to be sensitive to be
insensitive to that important issue so
this is where we are now as a society
where a guy has to explain that a
picture of himself holding a gun in a
prom picture with his daughter and her
boyfriend is a joke yes to explain that
to all of these people that again
already know they know that he's joking
which is the main reason why I think
there shouldn't be an explanation but
putting all that aside
I think what we really see here more
than an attack on guns we see an attack
on the role of fathers because it's a
it's a father's job to protect and
defend his family and he ought to be
protective and of his daughter he ought
to be protective of her dignity and
protective of her of her innocence
obviously feeley's photo was a
deliberately cartoonish exaggerated
humorous depiction of that role it
wasn't supposed to be serious but what
we see is that feminists are mad or
pretending to be mad about the role
itself
they hate the idea that a man would
protect his family especially that he
would protect his daughter they hate
that idea so this again goes back to the
piece that I wrote a few weeks ago about
the challenges that men face in this
culture where a man really can't win
because a man who is not there for his
family a man who does not protect his
family does not defend his family a man
who has no problem with his daughter
shacking up with any old scumbag that
sort of man is still rightfully derided
and shamed in our culture but a man who
does the opposite the opposite sort of
man is also derided and shamed in our
culture
so again mad men are left saying well
what do you want me to do what exactly
am i how am I supposed to be what would
make you people happy now I don't ask
that because I don't care what makes
anyone set anyone happy but a man who is
concerned with how society views him is
going to be very confused because nomads
literally no matter what he does he's
going to hear it and I'm not just
drawing
all of this from this one reaction to
this picture I'm drawing it from this
from society in general but there are
also plenty of other examples for
instance just look at if you really want
to get a headache okay if you if you if
you feel like having a migraine here's
what I recommend go on google and type
in father-daughter dance
just see all the blog posts that pop up
talking about how problematic and weird
and creepy and old-fashioned and
patriarchal these father-daughter dances
are because eat this is a good example
of how the role of the dad has become
this has become this evil creepy thing
here's a bit from an article on romper
dot-com titled father-daughter dances
are anything but innocent
a couple of few sentences
the writer says these aren't sweet they
aren't cute they're creepy and they seek
to enforce patriarchal notions of
femininity these little girls who are
taken out on dates by their fathers are
taught that men should do everything for
them men open the door men pull out the
chair men buy everything it's incumbent
on the man to ask questions and draw her
out
this is 2017 and newsflash women don't
need men to do things for them we don't
need some big bad patriarchal figure to
hold the door or complement our inner
beauty we deserve men who are equal
partners who share life's journey with
us and who treat us as equals
daddy-daughter day it's include and it
include an implicit power dynamic and
it's not in favor of the girl I mean
just imagine okay imagine being the sort
of person
who hears about a man taking his little
girl out on the father-daughter dance
and the first thing they think is
implicit power dynamic or imagine being
the sort of person who sees this you
know funny
nice cliched photo of jay Feely and sees
it as some kind of patriarchal
conspiracy and that he he thinks he owns
his daughter like a slave i mean this is
what i reaiiy i honest i pity i really
have a lot of pity for these people for
feminists and all these people in our
culture because they live in such a
miserable world
I can't imagine living in the world that
they think we live in I can't imagine
having that mindset
so what
is why why are so many people so hostile
to the idea of a man being a figure of
protection or security or authority in
the home and I think there are two
reasons the first reason is pretty
simple we have to remember that many
feminists are feminists because they had
no father in the home at least they
didn't have a good father that's not the
case in all four all of them of course
it's theoretically possible that a good
father could produce a feminist very
unlikely probably if your daughter ends
up being a radical feminist it means
that you as a dad screwed up big time
most likely but I mean it is I'm saying
it's theoretically possible you gotta
have a good father because people you
know human beings make their own choices
and even a woman who's raised right
could end up unfortunately going down
the path of feminism so most of them had
one way or another absent fathers and
there's this certain kind of childish
self-centeredness that's really common
in our society where people insist on
spreading around their misery and they
came from broken homes so they must
attack and hate homes that are not
broken it's envy and it even goes a
little bit beyond envy actually because
a really envious person knows that he
doesn't have something and so he covets
the people who do have it but here
though what we see so often in our
society are people who don't have a
certain good thing in this case an
intact family and so they insist that
the thing must not be good so rather
than trying to have what other people
have they say well nobody should have it
but second the reason why people
especially feminists lash out at men who
protect and provide is is really this
and I've said before feminists they
really hate masculinity I think we have
it wrong we don't really understand the
motivations behind modern feminism and I
and I say it myself just kind of for
lack just kind of for the sake of
argument or just it's sort of laziness
I'll say well feminists hate masculinity
because in a sense they do but I think
even deeper than that
they actually idolize masculinity
so it's more accurate to say they hate
men who are masculine
because they themselves want to be
masculine its masculinity itself as what
they idolize they want to be that so
they say well we don't need no man to
protect us this is 2018 we don't need
that because they have idolized
the ability to protect they have taken
this and decided that well this is
everyone should have that ability they
want it for themselves
the kind of physical masculine strength
that a man has they want it they hate it
when men show it because they want they
have idolized it they have said they
have decided that masculinity is really
the height of existence and that's why
you get all these silly movies with the
kick-butt female action hero so go
around beating up men and everything and
it's just again it's kind of this silly
childish thing that feminists do where
they say well men have all the action
heroes now we want some well one of the
reasons why men are the action heroes in
movies is because men are the action
heroes in real life and you're simply
not gonna get a woman who's running
around just hand-to-hand combat beating
up a bunch of strong beefy men that's
just that's that's not gonna happen
in real life and yeah it is a movie so
fictional things can happen but but
generally you want to move even an
action movie to be grounded in some
sense in reality so that's why typically
you don't have as many movies like that
but feminists covet the strength of men
they covet masculinity itself and
to have it or to use the common phrase
now they want to appropriate it which is
why if a woman had taken that exact same
photo that jay Feely took holding the
gun and everything feminists would have
celebrated it they would have said was
the greatest thing ever
because they don't hate toxic
masculinity they just hate that men are
so much better at being masculine and
they think they're in a competition with
men really in the end we should stop
saying that that feminists hate
masculinity what they really hate is
femininity
that's what they hate they hate
themselves they don't want to be
themselves they want to be men and so
they hate men who are men
because they see is some kind of
personal attack on them so that's what
lies underneath all this all this
controversy which as I said it's not
even a real controversy so maybe I
didn't even need to spend 20 minutes
explaining it but I just did so hope you
enjoyed it I'll talk to you tomorrow
have a great day everybody
you